and I start this I have you ever passed
a little time by looking at Google Earth
images of old neighborhoods you used to
live in I have not I actually know okay
well this man there's a man in
Wellington Florida who is looking at a
map of the Google Earth satellite image
of a neighborhood he used to live in in
Wellington Florida and he noticed
something suspicious so he zoomed in and
saw what appeared to be this a submerged
car I don't know how he saw that yeah I
don't know either but he noticed this he
contacted a homeowner nearby who used it
groan to confirm that yes indeed it is a
car the surprise came when police pulled
it out of the water they found the
skeletal remains of 40 year old William
molt who disappeared 22 years ago after
leaving a nightclub on the night of
November 7th 1997 he called his
girlfriend said he'd be home soon but he
never made it we don't know exactly what
happened but this live was interested in
this because that's actually the town my
father retired to and there are a lot of
ponds like that down there could have
been you who found it you never know
what's in there Wow